what's up guys my name is Jana and
welcome to episode 8 of 3d game
programming in Java now there are a few
things I want to talk about today but
first of all I want to sort of touch a
bit on on alpha support that we added
because I think I add that in like
episode 6 or something I didn't really
talk about how it worked or what it did
actually at all and that was because I
was in a bit of a hurry but now for time
and yeah so I'll explain it um basically
what we did by adding alpha support is
we allowed ourselves to sort of have
pixels that arm that didn't really you
know that didn't contain any value that
they didn't like show up basically and
the best way to show this is whoa so
with that there we go is let's just
if we hit debug I don't know what's
going on with this whole Reis I think
it's something to do with my screen
recording recorder wow that's crazy
there we go if we um
if we go ahead here and let's just um
multiply this by next and put five in
there
divided by four and we need brackets
then you'll see that we've sort of got
transparency now if you if you compare
it with what it was like that I can't
actually do this subtle it won't change
live there we go that's sort of solid as
you can see if you just remember what
that looks like
I mean test out at home um on your
computers yeah so you can see that sort
of did that and if we if we sort of
raise this code this if statement then
you'll see that ya know alpha support so
that's sort of what it did it enabled us
to sort of have I guess void pixels
pixels the contained no data and that's
that will be really important in the
future as you are as you would would
think yeah okay so the second thing I
wanted to do is this this sort of
just cut this animation method that
we're using right now isn't really like
it's not it's not really practical so
what I want to do is I want to sort of
create a class which handles it gets
timing so let's go ahead and enter in
this in this main package in this in our
main package which contains our display
class I'm going to make a class a new
class called game and it's going to be
very simple this is going to handle time
so we'll make a public variable an
integer or call time and I'll also make
a method public a public method void
we'll call it the clock tick and that's
just going to be adding one value at a
time one unit one unit at a time every
time is get it gets called and what
we'll do here is we'll come in and we'll
go game game and just import it and
we'll sort of replace all this stuff
with game time
and what else we need to do do that we
need to let's add I to it first of all
and then well we also need must assign
and know the usual the usual stuff I
don't know that let's just see what that
looks like okay yeah okay I'll stop game
into here because we we added a new
parameter to this this method called
game so we need to call that here and
let's go ahead and yeah we'll have to
okay off to create that object so
[Music]
private actually let's pop this right
here private game game and ya know RS
let's see if that works
what exception didn't work okay
let's actually read the exception a
nullpointerexception
okay so we've had two exceptions so far
in our quest for again and the first one
was in array index out of bounds
exception which basically said that you
know you tried to use more values in
your array then you could then it could
handle you try to use more more more
things in the array it ran out of bounds
you know you went out of bounds but here
it's a nullpointerexception so I'll
explain what that is
real quick basically a
nullpointerexception is telling us the
where we're trying to assign a value of
null we're trying to use an object with
the value of null in a place that we
actually can't so it needs to have a
value can't be kept it as null so I'm
not sure why we're doing that but if we
do that real quick so it's basically
saying it's game time
something to do with hmm oh actually
first of all let's add game tag into
here and we'll see if that hmm nothing
fix it okay well it's just I don't know
what's going on so this isn't some live
live debugging I'm doing for you guys um
hmm oh yeah of course
okay so we didn't actually assign
anything to game
that's probably why basically a gal
let's just see if this figures the first
yet it basically what we did wrong here
is we are is we we sort of we initialize
we created that object but we didn't
assign it to anything C was like screen
when we created screen we set screen
equal to something we set it equal to a
new screen to a new instance of that
class with two parameters we didn't do
anything for game though we just said
game game and that's certain you know
doesn't equal anything so Java
automatically thinks okay if you didn't
learn anything
is basically making it equal to null and
if we try and run this you know it it'll
fail it it'll turn it'll say that it's a
nullpointerexception because we can't
assign the value even all to this so
yeah we need to assign a new instance of
that object and now it works so yeah
that's nice um fix trailer that was
quick
good thing that was quick as well that
would have been embarrassing go away
okay so we've sort of got this I think
it's working properly
let's go ahead arm and game dot time
plus I let's just add in our time susp I
when I'm just safe that or if we get
there how we got to syntax are nothing
too fancy okay so that that's dead
moving that's for sure
let's go ahead and bring up what am i
doing okay interesting so there move
Ving or if we times up by 1,000
interesting that's not going to work
okay I'm just sort of playing around
with this right now trying to get to
work properly game DUP time plus I
actually okay so what did we have before
anims ero we had int we had system dot
current time milliseconds and we took
the remainder of that divided by
thousand and we also added that's right
we had a PI to it we multiplied by PI I
mean and then we multiply the whole
thing by 100 and that worked I think
just go ahead and okay
oh and we also say add methyl sign I
call it sign because sin is like the
abbreviation for sign what are you doing
here okay we don't need that that's
right okay let's save that and let's see
what this does
yeah see that worked okay interesting
let's do the same thing here and if we
add I to it yeah okay okay so let's sort
of try and mimic that here if we go
ahead and take that divided by that and
then multiply it by 100
see what that does okay so that's what
worked okay yeah that seems to work come
in here and do the same thing centage
we'll talk about a bit about what this
actually means this operator a bit later
basically it's taking the remainder of
that it's I'll we'll talk about that
next time because we don't have time
okay let's see what this save this works
yeah okay wonderful it did work sort of
actually okay let's just turn this arm
actually let's just times up I I this
should be crazy okay it's yeah it's fair
enough to say that worked I guess it's
not really doing the circle thing okay
it is doing the circle thing I wonder if
it's just okay no it's not that
okay um ten maybe wow that's really cool
okay I'm still playing around with this
um what if we sort of do that so go slot
it's still going way too fast though not
sure why just yes that's odd and we're
still getting a nice what's our frames
per second I are still working that's
all right
okay so yeah generally generally we get
that we're in the clear
times 1000 at summarise doesn't work at
all
okay let's just divide that by like two
or something make that work a bit better
100 okay there we go that's what yeah
let's battle
maybe times that by eight or something
maybe not okay and if we come into game
we can sort of change this to equal to
three or whatever and that'll make it go
a bit faster okay cool so that yes
that's working let's just delete this
and just minus plus thing going on yeah
okay there we go
okay awesome so we've we've got that
working the other thing I wanted to talk
about is basically what we're going to
do is we're going to move on to three
stuff probably next probably tomorrow so
to prepare for that I just want to do
one thing and instead of sort of having
this here like having having this
configuration here where we just have a
normal thing I want to actually make a
dimension out of it we'll call it size
equals a new dimension and basically
what I mentioned enables you to do is
it's sort of me it it'll it'll allow you
to put width and height into one object
which which will actually come in handy
quite a bit in the future so let's go
ahead and go set preferred size size set
minimum
sighs sighs and we'll set the maximum
sighs sighs so this is the safest way to
do it just to the net just to make sure
this is all good maximum and because of
that we we can actually remove words out
sighs if we can actually remove that
because it should work anyway and
awesome it does hey well what is good
what is that well it looks like we've
got a sort of a border thing happening
okay that's what is that the our second
problem that we've run into today that
shouldn't be there that's really weird
let's um yeah I'll try and fix that now
I don't mmm that's hmm well um I'll set
resizable to true and see if it if it
stays the same in the same place oh it's
not there at all oh yeah Wow
okay so it's like in so we just need to
feel a greater area I guess well that's
that's not good I don't know how that's
going to show up on the screen recorder
hmm okay so we just need to fill a large
area I guess okay let's let's try and do
this so what's filling the screen here
draw image let's try and there we go
that's gotten thinner plus five okay
awesome
so what is that like ten pixels I think
a stem yeah okay I fixed it yeah that's
mmm that I don't know why that was
happening actually that's really weird
hmm oh it's gone now it'll still be here
they're better so cake is not we haven't
actually made a result resizable true'
yup if we resize it I yeah it's still
going to be that but at least we've got
rid of it for now
that yeah that was weird
that's really weird okay so we fixed
sort of two burgers live today and yes
oh next time we're actually going to
move on to actually doing the
perspective like 3d stuff and we're
going to be we're going to be able to
put this into 3d and actually you know
maybe I don't know how far we'll get
because it's pretty complicated but I'll
try and explain it as as as good as
possible so yeah I'll see you guys later
bye
[Music]
[Music]